This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is a rebroadcast of an episode reported a few years ago by Christopher Johnson. It has really interesting history, it's about flags, it's everything I love in a story. So if you haven't heard it before, definitely listen to it. And if you have listened to it before, listen again, because I guarantee you don't remember the details. But if you want to hear a completely brand new episode of 99% Invisible about lifeboats on the Titanic, you can right now if you subscribe to SiriusXM Podcast Plus on Apple podcasts or visit siriusxm.com slash podcast plus to listen with Spotify or another app of your
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这是几年前由克里斯托弗·约翰逊报道的一期节目的重播。它有着非常有趣的历史，关于旗帜，它包含了所有我喜欢的故事元素。所以如果你以前没听过，一定要听听。如果你以前听过，那就再听一遍，因为我敢保证你已经不记得细节了。但如果你想听一期关于泰坦尼克号救生艇的《99% Invisible》全新剧集，你现在就可以订阅 Apple Podcasts 上的 SiriusXM Podcast Plus，或者访问 siriusxm.com/podcastplus，通过 Spotify 或其他你选择的应用程序收听。
choice. Non-subscribers will hear that very same story next week, so everything will be made available to all. But if you subscribe to SiriusXM Podcast Plus, you can hear episodes of 99% Invisible one week early and ad free. And subscribing goes a long way to support the work that we do here. Subscribe to SiriusXM Podcast Plus on Apple Podcasts or visit siriusxm.com slash podcastsplus to listen with Spotify or another app of your choice. Okay, on with the show. A quick heads up, this episode has some offensive language. After Minneapolis police officer Derek Chauvin murdered George Floyd last year, tens of thousands
非订阅用户下周就能听到同一期节目，所以所有人都能听到。但如果你订阅了 SiriusXM Podcast Plus，你可以提前一周收听《99% Invisible》的剧集，而且没有广告。订阅是对我们在这里所做工作的极大支持。在 Apple Podcasts 上订阅 SiriusXM Podcast Plus，或访问 siriusxm.com/podcastplus，通过 Spotify 或其他你选择的应用程序收听。好了，节目继续。温馨提示，本期节目包含一些冒犯性语言。去年明尼阿波利斯警官德里克·肖文谋杀乔治·弗洛伊德后，成千上万
of people all over the world took to the streets to protest police violence against black people. And if you look at images from these marches, you'll probably start to notice a common color scheme. Lots of red, black, and green. 99 PI producer, Christopher Johnson. You'll see those colors everywhere. Red, black, and green picket signs and banners, red, black, and green hoodies and hats,
世界各地的人们走上街头，抗议针对黑人的警察暴力。如果你看看这些游行的照片，你可能会开始注意到一种共同的配色方案。大量的红色、黑色和绿色。《99 PI》制作人，克里斯托弗·约翰逊。你会到处看到这些颜色。红色、黑色和绿色的纠察牌和横幅，红色、黑色和绿色的连帽衫和帽子，
and red, black, and green flags. Sometimes it's good to see that red, black, and green flag, particularly when there's times of strife and people are outraged and angry, and they start to come to that realization that we're not getting anywhere with the begging. Moriam Makamal has several of these flags in different sizes, including a huge one that he likes to fly outside of his house. He says that wherever there are protests or demonstrations against threats to Black life,
以及红色、黑色和绿色的旗帜。有时看到那面红、黑、绿旗帜是件好事，特别是在冲突时期，人们感到愤怒和愤慨，他们开始意识到，仅仅靠乞求是无法解决任何问题的。莫里亚姆·马卡马尔有几面不同尺寸的这种旗帜，包括他喜欢在屋子外面悬挂的一面巨大的旗帜。他说，无论哪里有针对威胁黑人生命行为的抗议或示威，
the red, black, and green will be there. When people are ready for more than what they've been getting and they're ready to challenge the system, then you see the red, black, and green flags come out. And not just at demonstrations. This tri-color scheme has been used on T-shirts, on high-top chucks, and in works of art that have sold for millions of dollars.
红色、黑色和绿色就会出现在那里。当人们准备好争取比现状更多的东西，并准备好挑战体制时，你就会看到红、黑、绿旗帜出现。而且不仅仅是在示威活动中。这种三色方案已被用于 T 恤、高帮帆布鞋以及售价数百万美元的艺术品中。
The flag was invented to unite black people all over the world who were living under racial repression. And when it first came into existence, the flag posed some bold questions about where black people owed their loyalty to the nations where their lives were demeaned and threatened, or to a new nation, one they'd built entirely for themselves. And for hundreds of thousands of black folks,
这面旗帜的发明是为了团结全世界生活在种族压迫下的黑人。当它最初出现时，这面旗帜提出了几个大胆的问题：黑人应该效忠于那些贬低和威胁他们生命的国家，还是效忠于一个全新的、完全由他们自己建立的国家？对于成千上万的黑人来说，
the red, black, and green symbolized the answer. The flag has been in use since 1918, but I'm gonna start a couple decades before that with the story of a super racist song about flags. In the beginning of the 20th century, there was vaudeville, there was minstrelsy in America, and there was this tradition of coon songs. Can I say that word, Christopher?
红色、黑色和绿色象征着答案。这面旗帜自 1918 年以来一直在使用，但我将从几十年前关于一首关于旗帜的超级种族主义歌曲的故事讲起。20 世纪初，美国有杂耍表演，有吟游诗人表演，还有一种“黑鬼歌曲”（coon songs）的传统。克里斯托弗，我能说那个词吗？
This is writer and historian Colin Grant. He's talking about an old style of American music that's named after a racial slur. Coon songs were exactly what they sound like. The lyrics were deeply racist, based on gross stereotypes about black life and speech patterns, usually sung over ragtime piano. And in 1900, one of the biggest songs of the genre came out. There was a very famous Coon song called
这是作家兼历史学家科林·格兰特。他谈论的是一种以种族歧视用语命名的老式美国音乐。“黑鬼歌曲”正如其名。歌词极其种族主义，基于对黑人生活和言语模式的粗俗刻板印象，通常伴随着拉格泰姆钢琴曲演唱。1900 年，该流派最著名的歌曲之一问世了。有一首非常有名的“黑鬼歌曲”叫
Every Race Has a Flag But the Coon. It was a song that lampooned black people for not having their own flag and lampooned them for the idea that they should have their own flag. Two white composers wrote the song and I got somebody to play the sheet music for me. Here's what it sounds like.
《每个种族都有旗帜，除了黑鬼》（Every Race Has a Flag But the Coon）。这首歌嘲讽黑人没有自己的旗帜，并嘲讽他们想要拥有自己旗帜的想法。两位白人作曲家写了这首歌，我找人帮我弹奏了乐谱。听起来是这样的。
["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"]
["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"] In the lyrics, the head of a black social club gets up to speak, and he says he's just come back from a Labor Day parade where he saw all these different races proudly waving their national flags. Ireland has her harp in shamrock, England floats her lion bold, even China waves a dragon, Germany an Eagle Gold. And then he comes to the US.
["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"] ["The Sheep"] 在歌词中，一个黑人社交俱乐部的负责人站起来发言，他说他刚从劳动节游行回来，在那里他看到所有不同的种族都在自豪地挥舞着他们的国旗。爱尔兰有她的竖琴和三叶草，英国飘扬着她大胆的狮子，甚至中国也挥舞着龙，德国挥舞着金鹰。然后他提到了美国。
And what won't Yankees do for the old red, white and blue? The lyrics seem to drive at the idea that the Stars and Stripes didn't belong to black people, that they'd need something else to represent them. The song went on to propose a flag for black people that's crammed with all these racist stereotypes. Every race has a flag, was performed by more than a hundred touring vaudeville acts, and was part of the vaudeville circuit for more than three decades.
“扬基人为了那古老的红、白、蓝会做什么呢？”歌词似乎旨在传达这样一个观点：星条旗不属于黑人，他们需要别的东西来代表他们。这首歌接着为黑人提议了一面塞满了所有这些种族主义刻板印象的旗帜。《每个种族都有旗帜》由一百多个巡回杂耍表演团体表演，并在杂耍巡回演出中存在了三十多年。
It was huge. Which isn't surprising given the era. The US wasn't even two generations out of slavery. Jim Crow and Separate But Equal were in full effect. Lynching and other terrorist violence surged. Black Americans were getting the message from all sides, including popular music, that they weren't respected or safe or really even considered fully American.
它非常火爆。考虑到那个时代，这并不令人惊讶。美国距离废除奴隶制还不到两代人。吉姆·克劳法和“隔离但平等”政策全面生效。私刑和其他恐怖暴力激增。美国黑人从四面八方，包括流行音乐中得到的信息是，他们不受尊重，不安全，甚至根本不被视为完全的美国人。
Now, as gross as the song was, the lyrics hinted at something that did resonate for Black folks. That actually a flag was something that enabled people to be welded together. That idea was one which many Black people understood. And in particular, a Jamaican-born labor organizer and journalist named Marcus Garvey. In the early 1900s, Garvey bounced around Central and South America trying to start some advocacy newspapers fighting for working black people. But he wasn't having much luck.
现在，尽管这首歌很恶心，但歌词暗示了一些确实引起黑人共鸣的东西。那就是，旗帜确实是一种能让人们团结在一起的东西。这个想法是许多黑人所理解的。特别是牙买加出生的劳工组织者和记者马库斯·加维。20 世纪初，加维在中美洲和南美洲奔波，试图创办一些为劳动黑人争取权益的倡导报纸。但他运气不太好。
Garvey wanted more work opportunities and some adventure. He was also curious to see how black people like himself were living in other parts of the British Empire. So in 1912, he set off across the Atlantic. Young Marcus Garvey in his mid-20s, he went to England at that time for someone in the British colonies. London is where you would go
加维想要更多的工作机会和一些冒险。他也很好奇像他这样的黑人在大英帝国的其他地方是如何生活的。于是，1912 年，他横渡大西洋。年轻的马库斯·加维二十多岁时去了英国，当时对于英国殖民地的人来说，伦敦是你想要
to try to establish yourself, to say, I have arrived, I'm going to partake of this splendid imperial enterprise, which the British had ruled over for centuries, he's going to go to the heart of empire. In London, Garvey landed a gig at a newspaper that carried stories about Black life throughout the diaspora. He also got a pass to the British Museum, which had a large library. Garvey began reading ideas totally new to him, ideas that came to be known as Pan-Africanism.
试图建立自己地位的地方，去说“我来了，我要参与这个辉煌的帝国事业”。英国统治了几个世纪，他要去帝国的中心。在伦敦，加维在一家报纸找到了一份工作，该报纸报道了整个散居地黑人的生活。他还获得了大英博物馆的通行证，那里有一个大型图书馆。加维开始阅读对他来说全新的思想，这些思想后来被称为泛非主义。
Pan-Africanism is concerned with the unity and liberation of Africa and people of African heritage. I like to think of it as a mighty river with many streams and currents. Hakeem Adi, a professor of African and Black diaspora history says, the source of that river is the transatlantic slave trade. Slavery forced together millions of people
泛非主义关注非洲和非洲裔人民的团结与解放。我喜欢把它想象成一条拥有许多支流和水流的强大河流。非洲和黑人散居史教授哈基姆·阿迪说，这条河的源头是跨大西洋奴隶贸易。奴隶制强行将数百万人聚集在一起
from across the African continent. Adi believes Pan-Africanism started there, more than 400 years ago. It developed as those people with different languages and cultures began to understand their shared conditions and then aligned to change them. By the early 20th century, Black intellectuals had done a lot of thinking and writing about global Africa-centered Black identity. Ideas about repatriation, ideas about the importance of independent states like Haiti, like Ethiopia, like Liberia, ideas about colonialism and what needed to be done to reform it, and
来自非洲大陆各地。阿迪认为泛非主义始于 400 多年前。随着那些拥有不同语言和文化的人开始理解他们共同的处境，并联合起来改变它们，它便发展起来了。到了 20 世纪初，黑人知识分子对全球以非洲为中心的黑人身份进行了大量的思考和写作。关于遣返的思想，关于海地、埃塞俄比亚、利比里亚等独立国家重要性的思想，关于殖民主义以及需要做些什么来改革它的思想，以及
ideas about the glories of historic African civilization. So it's in this sort of context that Garvey and his work develop. One big part of this development was the way Garvey thought about Africa. As a kid, he'd been taught that Africans were primitive and backwards with no history to speak of. What he'd read in London told him the opposite was true. Garvey realized that Africa could be the center of racial pride for all of black humanity. Along with this pan-African thought, Garvey was also heavily influenced by writings about black self-sufficiency, the call to build a black world that was economically, politically,
关于历史悠久的非洲文明辉煌的思想。所以，正是在这种背景下，加维和他的工作得以发展。这种发展的一个重要部分是加维对非洲的看法。小时候，他被教导说非洲人是原始和落后的，没有历史可言。他在伦敦读到的东西告诉他事实恰恰相反。加维意识到，非洲可以成为全人类黑人种族自豪感的中心。除了这种泛非思想，加维还深受关于黑人自给自足的著作的影响，即建立一个在经济、政治上
and culturally independent from white society. Garvey combined these ideas with his newfound Afrocentrism, and a political philosophy started to emerge. It had been just two years since Marcus Garvey had arrived in London. He'd left Jamaica hoping to find work and for a chance to see more of the world. But what he found in the heart of the British Empire, the seat of a massive colonial power,
和文化上独立于白人社会的黑人世界的呼吁。加维将这些思想与他新发现的非洲中心主义相结合，一种政治哲学开始浮现。距离马库斯·加维抵达伦敦才仅仅两年。他离开牙买加时希望能找到工作，并有机会看看这个世界。但他在大英帝国的中心，这个庞大殖民力量的所在地所发现的，
was the way he thought to free the entire Black world. Garvey became convinced that Black people in Africa colonial power was the way he thought to free the entire black world. Garvey became convinced that black people in Africa and throughout the diaspora share a common identity. They also shared a responsibility to advance the race and to protect it. And the safest place for them was one built solely by black hands. The idea that you had to forge a nation of your own, that you couldn't trust the man to look after yourself. And when I say the man, I mean the imperial powers. We're not going to further the likes of someone like Marcus Garvey or the Black people over whom they ruled.
是他认为解放整个黑人世界的方法。加维确信，非洲的黑人殖民力量是他认为解放整个黑人世界的方法。加维确信，非洲和整个散居地的黑人拥有共同的身份。他们也肩负着推进种族进步和保护种族的责任。而对他们来说最安全的地方，是完全由黑人之手建立的地方。那种你必须锻造一个属于自己的国家，你不能指望“那个人”（白人统治者）来照顾你的想法。当我提到“那个人”时，我指的是帝国列强。我们不会去推进像马库斯·加维这样的人，或者他们所统治的黑人的利益。
And Garvey recognized through reading that actually he could conjure an alternative to the reality in which he found himself. He could change the narrative. Garvey sailed back to the Caribbean in 1914. This was still several years before he'd make the red, black and green flag that he intended to stand for all of black humanity. But he was already thinking about how to build the kind of nation that such a flag would represent. On the ship going back from England to Jamaica, he famously said to himself,
加维通过阅读认识到，实际上他可以创造一个替代他所处现实的选择。他可以改变叙事。加维于 1914 年乘船回到加勒比海。这距离他制作那面他打算代表全人类黑人的红、黑、绿旗帜还有几年时间。但他已经在思考如何建立一个这样的旗帜所代表的国家。在从英国回牙买加的船上，他对自己说了一句名言：
where is the black man's army? Where is the black man's military chief? He looked about and he saw none. All he saw was subjugation. And he said to himself, he was going to build that army, and he was going to establish a new African empire. Garvey put his Pan-African thinking to work almost as soon as he landed in Jamaica. He formed an organization called the UNIA, the Universal Negro Improvement Association.
“黑人的军队在哪里？黑人的军事首领在哪里？”他环顾四周，什么也没看到。他看到的只有征服。于是他对自己说，他要建立那支军队，他要建立一个新的非洲帝国。加维一回到牙买加，就立即将他的泛非主义思想付诸实践。他成立了一个名为 UNIA 的组织，即“世界黑人进步协会”（Universal Negro Improvement Association）。
Its primary objective was to establish a universal confraternity among the race. Here's how Garvey described the UNIA many years later. Hello, citizens of Africa. I greet you in the name of the Universal Negro Pumat Association, an organization that seeks to unite into one solid body the 400 million Negroes of the world for the purpose of bettering our industrial, commercial, educational, social, and political conditions. But the UNIA got off to a so-so start. Garvey once again found himself strapped for cash.
其主要目标是在种族之间建立一种普遍的兄弟情谊。以下是加维多年后描述 UNIA 的方式：“你好，非洲的公民们。我以世界黑人进步协会的名义向你们致意，这是一个旨在将全世界 4 亿黑人团结成一个坚实整体的组织，目的是改善我们的工业、商业、教育、社会和政治状况。”但 UNIA 的开局平平。加维再次发现自己手头拮据。
So to raise money and build a following, he left Jamaica again. This time he headed to Harlem. And that's where Marcus Garvey really took off as a race leader. America is the seat of wealth, is the seat of promise, is the seat of any person who has some ambition that wants to have a bigger canvas to realize his ambition. So he was a young man in his mid to late 20s. He came with a hope and a prayer
因此，为了筹集资金并建立追随者，他再次离开了牙买加。这一次，他前往哈莱姆。在那里，马库斯·加维真正作为一名种族领袖崛起。“美国是财富的所在地，是希望的所在地，是任何有抱负、想要有更大舞台来实现自己抱负的人的所在地。”所以他当时是一个二十多岁的中青年。他带着希望和祈祷而来，
with not too far then to rub together. When Garvey arrived in 1916, Harlem was going through some major changes of its own. The black population there had been searching for about a dozen years. Folks were coming from other parts of New York City, from down south, and like Garvey, from the Caribbean. It was the beginning of the so-called New Negro era, or the Negro Renaissance. In art and politics,
身上没带多少钱。当加维于 1916 年抵达时，哈莱姆本身正在经历一些重大的变化。那里的黑人人口已经增长了大约十二年。人们从纽约市的其他地方、从南方，以及像加维一样，从加勒比海地区来到这里。那是所谓的“新黑人时代”或“黑人文艺复兴”的开始。在艺术和政治上，
Black Harlemites from throughout the diaspora argued furiously over what it meant to be Black. Garvey jumped headlong into the debate. He'd stand on one of Harlem's famous soap boxes and address a crowd with his nascentcent pan-Africanist ideas. But not everybody was feeling young Marcus Garvey, including the era's most famous black intellectual. The premier man, the premier leader at that time was W.E.B. Du Bois. And his organization, the NAACP, had captured the imagination of black people. At the time, Du Bois was ascendant. W.E.B. Du Bois felt that full civil rights
来自整个散居地的哈莱姆黑人激烈地争论着身为黑人意味着什么。加维一头扎进了这场辩论。他会站在哈莱姆著名的肥皂箱上，用他萌芽中的泛非主义思想向人群发表演讲。但并不是每个人都看好年轻的马库斯·加维，包括那个时代最著名的黑人知识分子。当时的首要人物、首要领袖是 W.E.B. 杜波依斯。他的组织，全国有色人种协进会（NAACP），已经俘获了黑人的想象力。当时，杜波依斯正处于上升期。W.E.B. 杜波依斯认为，充分的公民权利
were the keys to black freedom in a country that was hostile to their survival and peace. He believed in America as a viable nation for black folks. It would take real struggle, but there was a path for black people to be whole and safe under the stars and stripes. Marcus Garvey saw things totally differently. He came to believe that the fundamental problem for black people in the West was the West itself. There was no way the US or Great Britain or any
是在一个对他们的生存与和平充满敌意的国家中实现黑人自由的关键。他相信美国是一个适合黑人的可行国家。这需要真正的斗争，但黑人在星条旗下是有可能变得完整和安全的。马库斯·加维的看法完全不同。他开始相信，黑人在西方所面临的根本问题就是西方本身。美国、英国或任何
other Western power was going to let black people be truly free. We are not going to be black people be truly free. Garvey believed that black people were, as he put it, a mighty race, and that the only way for them to realize their full potential and to survive the anti-blackness of the West was to come together and build a separate black world. Babylon did it. France and the Napoleon did it. America under George Washington did it. Africa with 400 million black people can do it. If you cannot do what other men have done, what other nations have done, what other races have done, then you have better die. The more time Garvey spent in the US, the firmer that position became. In the South, he'd witnessed firsthand the struggles of rural black America living under
其他西方列强根本不可能让黑人真正自由。我们不可能让黑人真正自由。加维认为，黑人正如他所说，是一个“强大的种族”，他们实现全部潜力并从西方的反黑人情绪中幸存下来的唯一途径，就是团结起来，建立一个独立的黑人世界。“巴比伦做到了。法国和拿破仑做到了。乔治·华盛顿领导下的美国做到了。拥有 4 亿黑人的非洲也能做到。如果你不能做到其他人做到的事，其他国家做到的事，其他种族做到的事，那你最好去死。”加维在美国待的时间越长，这一立场就越坚定。在南方，他亲眼目睹了生活在
Jim Crow. He'd come from Jamaican society, where class often outweighed race privilege. But in the US, he noticed that was flipped, a dynamic which inspired Garvey to center his message on blackness. He believed that actually race should come before class, that you only became powerful by uniting together, by having a powerful voice through sheer numbers. Therefore, we should cleave together as Black people and place primacy on race. Then something happened that put the difference between Du Bois and Garvey in sharp relief and gave Garvey an opportunity to really articulate the Pan-Africanist vision that he'd been
吉姆·克劳法下的美国农村黑人的挣扎。他来自牙买加社会，在那里阶级往往超过种族特权。但在美国，他注意到情况反过来了，这种动态激发了加维将他的信息集中在“黑人身份”上。他认为，实际上种族应该先于阶级，你只有通过团结一致，通过纯粹的人数拥有强大的声音，才能变得强大。因此，我们应该作为黑人紧密团结在一起，并将种族置于首位。然后发生了一件事，使杜波依斯和加维之间的分歧变得鲜明，并给了加维一个机会，真正阐述他自
developing since his days at the British Museum. America has called to arms. The first volunteers are cheered, thousands of them and millions more to follow. When Woodrow Wilson brought America into the First World War under the idea that they were going to make the world safe for democracy, Garvey
在英国博物馆时期以来一直在发展的泛非主义愿景。“美国发出了武装号召。第一批志愿者受到欢呼，成千上万的人，还有数百万随之而来。”当伍德罗·威尔逊以“让世界安全以实现民主”为理念将美国带入第一次世界大战时，加维
would stand on his soapbox and say, that's all very well, Woodrow Wilson, but how about making Georgia safer for the black man first? The U.S. entered World War I in April 1917. That summer, there was large-scale racial violence in several cities. Some of the worst was in East St. Louis. A labor dispute turned into an all-out assault on the city's black residents. Whites set fire to black neighborhoods. White snipers shot and killed black people in the streets. There were mob beatings and lynchings. The suddenness and the sheer shock of the violence of East St. Louis changed everybody. And yet Woodrow Wilson was going to take America into the war
会站在他的肥皂箱上说：“伍德罗·威尔逊，这很好，但先让佐治亚州对黑人更安全怎么样？”美国于 1917 年 4 月参加第一次世界大战。那年夏天，几个城市发生了大规模的种族暴力事件。最严重的一些发生在东圣路易斯。一场劳资纠纷演变成了对该市黑人居民的全面攻击。白人放火烧毁了黑人社区。白人狙击手在街上射杀黑人。发生了暴徒殴打和私刑。东圣路易斯暴力的突然性和纯粹的冲击力改变了所有人。然而，伍德罗·威尔逊却要将美国带入战争，
because America was this great savior without recognizing that many of the transgressions that were going to be challenged in Europe also existed on home soil. Sometimes Gardy would respond to racist violence with calls for revenge or armed self-defense. The boys and the NAACP stood firmly against this approach. The two men also disagreed on whether or not black men should enlist to fight in Europe, given the racial climate in the US. So whereas Du Bois said we must forget our differences between ourselves as black people and the white men, we must put our shoulder to the wheel and fight the common enemy, Garvey
因为美国是这个伟大的救世主，却没有意识到许多将在欧洲受到挑战的罪行也存在于本土。有时，加维会以呼吁复仇或武装自卫来回应种族主义暴力。杜波依斯和 NAACP 坚定地反对这种做法。两人还对在种族气候如此恶劣的美国，黑人是否应该应征去欧洲作战存在分歧。所以，当杜波依斯说“我们必须忘记我们黑人之间与白人之间的分歧，我们必须肩并肩，共同对抗共同的敌人”时，加维
was saying the very opposite. Garvey was saying, no, do not go off and fight the white man's war for him, because come the end of the war, things were revert to the way that they'd been before. And that's exactly what happened. As those soldiers came back and some of them were even lynched in their uniforms, there were many people who saw that Garvey had been right. The idea that World War I would make things better for black people didn't pan out. In fact, as the war ended, cities and towns across the US exploded in an unprecedented
说的恰恰相反。加维说：“不，不要去为白人打仗，因为战争结束时，一切都会恢复到以前的样子。”而这正是发生的事情。当那些士兵回来，甚至有些人穿着制服被私刑处死时，许多人看到加维是对的。第一次世界大战会让黑人生活变得更好的想法并没有实现。事实上，随着战争结束，美国各地的城市和城镇爆发了前所未有的
wave of anti-black violence. It had been 50 years since black Americans were declared full citizens of the US. Black people had invested in the democratic process. And now they'd gone overseas and fought and died under the stars and stripes. And yet the country's deadly racial caste system stayed firmly in place, just as Marcus Garvey had predicted. And I think that made him seem, in the eyes of many Black people, a kind of prophet, a
反黑人暴力浪潮。距离美国黑人被宣布为美国完全公民已经 50 年了。黑人投资了民主进程。现在他们已经出国，在星条旗下战斗并牺牲。然而，这个国家致命的种族种姓制度依然稳固，正如马库斯·加维所预言的那样。我认为这使他在许多黑人眼中看起来像是一位先知，一位
seer, someone who could see into the future, but also someone who was fearless. I mean, he was fearless. And that was very empowering. People wanted to align themselves with him. They saw that he was a winner. Garvey had been adding up events in cities like East St. Louis. He saw what was happening to Black soldiers and civilians alike. If the question was, to whom do Black people owe their loyalty?
预言家，一个能看穿未来的人，但也是一个无所畏惧的人。我的意思是，他无所畏惧。这非常赋权。人们想要与他结盟。他们看到他是一个赢家。加维一直在累加东圣路易斯等城市的事件。他看到了黑人士兵和平民身上发生的事情。如果问题是，黑人应该效忠于谁？
Garvey's answer was clear. Black people owe their loyalty first to other Black people. He recognized that, in his mind anyway, that black people were Africans in exile in America. And there was going to be no place for them. There was no future for them in America. But Marcus Garvey had a plan. They had to get out and they had to establish their own place.
加维的答案很明确。黑人首先效忠于其他黑人。他认识到，在他看来，黑人是流亡在美国的非洲人。他们将无处可去。在美国，他们没有未来。但马库斯·加维有一个计划。他们必须离开，他们必须建立自己的地方。
And that place was going to be Africa. Garvey believed that every single black person on the planet was an African, and that the continent was their birthright. He said Africa should be free of colonial rule, so that black people themselves can develop their own societies there. For 250 years we have struggled under the burden and rigors of slavery. We were maimed, we were brutalized, we were ravaged in every way. We are men. We have hopes, we have passions, we have feelings, we have desires just like any other race. And so Garvey would be calling for Africa for the Africans, those at home and those abroad. The cries raised all over the world of Canada for the Canadians, of America for the Americans,
而那个地方就是非洲。加维认为地球上的每一个黑人都是非洲人，非洲大陆是他们的与生俱来的权利。他说非洲应该摆脱殖民统治，这样黑人自己才能在那里发展自己的社会。“250 年来，我们在奴隶制的重负和严酷下挣扎。我们被残害，被虐待，在各方面被蹂躏。我们是人。我们有希望，我们有激情，我们有感情，我们有欲望，就像任何其他种族一样。”所以加维会呼吁“非洲属于非洲人，无论是在国内还是在国外”。全世界都在高呼“加拿大属于加拿大人，美国属于美国人，
of England for the English, of France for the French, of Germany for the Germans. Do you take it unreasonably we the Blacks of the world should raise the cry of Africa for the Canadians, for the Americans, for the Americans of England, for the English, for France, for the French, for Germany, for the Germans. Do you think it unreasonable that we the Black people of the world should raise the cry of Africa for the Africans? Yeah! Yeah! Yeah! Garvey had long understood that he needed cohesion in order to achieve his dream of an independent Black world.
英国属于英国人，法国属于法国人，德国属于德国人”。你认为我们全世界的黑人发出“非洲属于非洲人”的呼声是不合理的吗？是的！是的！是的！加维早就明白，为了实现他建立独立黑人世界的梦想，他需要凝聚力。
The campaign for a homeland would fail if Black people didn't see themselves as a single global race. How are you going to cleave those people of that race together? What can you do to reimagine a society where whiteness is not the thing that defines you? You're not in opposition to whiteness. You are just Black. You are just black. You are just your own people. Ironically, part of the answer came from white people. Garvey drew on what he'd seen years earlier in London.
如果黑人不把自己视为一个单一的全球种族，那么建立家园的运动就会失败。你如何将那个种族的那些人团结在一起？你能做些什么来重新构想一个不以“白人身份”来定义你的社会？你不是在反对白人。你只是黑人。你只是黑人。你只是你自己的人民。讽刺的是，部分答案来自白人。加维借鉴了他多年前在伦敦所见的东西。
He was inspired by how the British used symbols to flex their strength and to unite people across their vast empire. He saw the great buildings of power. He saw these great columns with these admirals on top of them. He saw the way that the British celebrated their history through symbols of conquest, through symbols of authority. I think he really understood the power of symbols
他受到英国人如何利用符号来展示力量并团结他们庞大帝国人民的启发。他看到了宏伟的权力建筑。他看到了那些顶部有海军上将的巨大圆柱。他看到了英国人如何通过征服的象征、权威的象征来庆祝他们的历史。我认为他真正理解了符号的力量，
to enliven people, to conjure this notion that you are part of something greater than yourself. Garvey had taken note of all the trappings of nationhood. He was very influenced by the idea that the show of power came through things like the idea of planting yourself under a flag, of saying that you belong to a group. He recognized that that's what imperial powers did. Marcus Garvey filtered all of that inspiration through his Black nationalist prism, and out came a flag, a banner that would stand for the entire Black world. Oh yes, the cause is grand, the cause is glorious. Surely we shall not turn back.
去激励人们，去唤起这种“你是比你自己更伟大的事物的一部分”的观念。加维注意到了所有国家地位的象征。他深受“展示力量来自于诸如在旗帜下扎根、宣称你属于一个群体”等想法的影响。他认识到这就是帝国列强所做的。马库斯·加维通过他的黑人民族主义棱镜过滤了所有这些灵感，于是出现了一面旗帜，一面代表整个黑人世界的旗帜。“哦，是的，事业是宏伟的，事业是光荣的。我们当然不会回头。”
Oh, sail on, sail on, sail on is glorious. Surely we shall not turn back. Oh sail on, sail on, sail on, oh mighty ship of state, sail on. Sail on until the flag of the red and the black and the green is put to the heels of South Africa. Garvey designed the Pan-African flag as a rectangle with three horizontal bars, red on top, then black, and green at the bottom. According to the UNIA, the red stands for the blood spilled in the fight to protect and defend Africa. Green represents Africa itself,
“哦，航行吧，航行吧，航行吧，是光荣的。我们当然不会回头。哦，航行吧，航行吧，航行吧，哦，强大的国家之船，航行吧。航行吧，直到红、黑、绿的旗帜插在南非的土地上。”加维将泛非旗帜设计为一个长方形，有三条水平横条，顶部是红色，中间是黑色，底部是绿色。根据 UNIA 的说法，红色代表在保护和捍卫非洲的斗争中流下的鲜血。绿色代表非洲本身，
its lushness and the motherland that Garveyites saw as their birthright. And black stands for the people of the continent and the diaspora. Garvey introduced the Pan-African banner in 1918, and it quickly became the symbol of his rapidly growing international movement. And that success came partly from the sheer potency of Garvey's message, which he spread throughout the Americas during these exhausting speaking tours. Plus, the UNIA's newspaper circulated Garveyism all over the world. And then there was Garvey's single biggest recruiting tool, the UNIA's commercial and
它的郁郁葱葱和加维主义者视为与生俱来权利的祖国。黑色代表非洲大陆和散居地的黑人。加维于 1918 年推出了泛非旗帜，它很快成为他迅速发展的国际运动的象征。这种成功部分归功于加维信息的纯粹力量，他在这些令人筋疲力尽的巡回演讲中将其传播到整个美洲。此外，UNIA 的报纸将加维主义传播到世界各地。还有加维最大的招募工具，UNIA 的商业和
passenger steamships called the Black Star Line. Garvey wanted a fleet that would sail between ports in North and South America, the Caribbean and Africa. The Black Star Line would be 100% black owned and operated. In a world where public transportation was often segregated and black people were routinely limited to the lowest classes of travel, the Black Star Line promised comfort, respect, safety, and speed to its black passengers. 5,000 black folks showed up to watch the first Black Star Line ship leave its East Harlem port in 1919.
客运蒸汽船，名为“黑星航运”（Black Star Line）。加维想要一支在北美和南美、加勒比海和非洲港口之间航行的船队。黑星航运将 100% 由黑人拥有和经营。在一个公共交通经常被隔离、黑人通常被限制在最低等级旅行的世界里，黑星航运承诺为黑人乘客提供舒适、尊重、安全和速度。1919 年，5000 名黑人来到现场观看第一艘黑星航运船离开其东哈莱姆港口。
According to at least one observer, the crowd was delirious with excitement. The Black Star Line never got as big as Garvey had envisioned, but it inspired pride and hope in Black people around the world. There was even a song about the ships, recorded while they were still active. Each and every one of those Black Star Line vessels hoisted the red, black and green colors from its masts. And when those ships came into harbor with the UNI flags flapping. There was the most extraordinary excitement because that was a manifestation of something that they thought to be impossible.
据至少一位观察者称，人群兴奋得近乎疯狂。黑星航运从未达到加维所设想的规模，但它激发了世界各地黑人的自豪感和希望。甚至还有一首关于这些船的歌，是在它们还在运营时录制的。每一艘黑星航运的船只都在桅杆上悬挂着红、黑、绿的颜色。当那些船只带着 UNIA 的旗帜飘扬着进入港口时，
So the flags on board the ships acted to promote the growth and the huge ambition and reach of Marcus Garvey and the Universal Negro Improvement Association, but for the flags and the ships, there would be no mass movement. They needed those symbols in order for the movement to grow. Without those flags, there would be no Marcus Garvey in our memory. Garvey to me is the, I call him the standard bearer of success under duress, who was blessed to do far more with less. Moria Makamao is the official historian of the UNIA.
那种兴奋是极其非凡的，因为那是他们认为不可能的事情的体现。所以船上的旗帜起到了促进马库斯·加维和世界黑人进步协会的成长以及巨大雄心和影响力的作用，如果没有旗帜和船只，就不会有群众运动。他们需要这些符号才能使运动成长。没有那些旗帜，我们的记忆中就不会有马库斯·加维。对我来说，加维是……我称他为在压力下成功的旗手，他有幸用更少的东西做了更多的事。莫里亚·马卡马奥是 UNIA 的官方历史学家。
Make sure you also call him the outrunner and the outdoer and out of this world, third rock from the sun bar none, as far as I'm concerned. By the end of the decade, Garvey's movement was massive. Two million people had joined the UNIA. as far as I'm concerned. By the end of the decade, Garvey's movement was massive. Two million people had joined the UNIA. It would eventually become the largest organization in black history, and its members proudly flew the Pan-African banner. Yeah, you would see a lot of houses with red, black, and green flags on the outside, as
确保你也称他为“先行者”、“超越者”和“超凡脱俗者”，就我而言，他是太阳系第三颗行星上无可争议的佼佼者。到十年结束时，加维的运动规模巨大。两百万人加入了 UNIA。到最后，它成为了黑人历史上最大的组织，其成员自豪地悬挂着泛非旗帜。是的，你会看到很多房子的外面挂着红、黑、绿旗帜，
well as mass meetings in local cities all around the globe. They would have red, black, and green flags whenever they had meetings, red, black, and green buttons as well on the lapel. And even some of the ministers would have their robes with red, black, and green when they were preaching the gospel of Garveyism. In 1920, the UNIA held its convention in New York City. It was a sprawling, month-long affair attended by tens of thousands of people. And there, the UNIA officially declared red, black, and green the colors of the Negro race. Then those colors were put on spectacular display when the UNIA held a massive parade
以及全球各地当地城市的大规模集会。只要他们有会议，他们就会有红、黑、绿旗帜，翻领上也有红、黑、绿徽章。甚至一些牧师在宣讲加维主义福音时，他们的长袍上也会有红、黑、绿的颜色。1920 年，UNIA 在纽约市举行了大会。这是一场为期一个月、规模宏大的活动，有数万人参加。在那里，UNIA 正式宣布红、黑、绿色为黑人种族的颜色。然后，当 UNIA 举行大规模游行时，这些颜色得到了壮观的展示，
meant to conjure a state procession. The flag was part of this medley of symbols that Garvey used to project to the world Black unity, strength and greatness. Primarily Marcus Garvey was a showman and in 1920 Marcus Garvey put on the greatest show on earth and he had the uniform of authority with his Victorian military regalia with his bicorneet helmet and his plumes in his helmet. There were huge choirs of a hundred and more on the streets walking with him.
旨在唤起一种国家游行的感觉。这面旗帜是加维用来向世界展示黑人团结、力量和伟大的符号组合的一部分。马库斯·加维主要是一位表演者，1920 年，马库斯·加维上演了地球上最伟大的表演，他穿着权威的制服，戴着维多利亚时代的军装，戴着双角头盔，头盔上插着羽毛。街上有成百上千人的巨大合唱团与他同行。
There were uniformed guards with their sabers rattling. There were placards saying, our time has come, down with lynching. There were bands playing. There was a spirit of carnival. It was the thing you wanted to be a part of. And it was a street performance that led to the most magnificent statement of Black intent that there'd ever been. But Marcus Garvey also drew a lot of fire. Federal investigators had been after Garvey since he first came to the U.S.
有穿着制服、佩剑叮当作响的卫兵。有写着“我们的时代到了”、“打倒私刑”的标语牌。有乐队在演奏。有一种狂欢节的精神。这是你想成为其中一部分的事情。这是一场街头表演，导致了有史以来最宏伟的黑人意图声明。但马库斯·加维也招致了很多攻击。联邦调查人员自他第一次来到美国以来就一直在追踪加维。
And at the same time, W.E.B. Du Bois and other black leaders were also coming for Garvey. They said his talk of an African empire was foolish. They called his business dealings shady and said that they were especially dangerous to the working class black people who invested in them. Others saw the UNIA's pomp and military regalia as clownish and embarrassing to the race. A campaign called Garvey Must Go pressured law enforcement to redouble their investigation of the UNIA.
与此同时，W.E.B. 杜波依斯和其他黑人领袖也在攻击加维。他们说他关于非洲帝国的言论是愚蠢的。他们称他的商业交易是阴暗的，并说这对投资其中的劳动阶级黑人尤其危险。其他人认为 UNIA 的排场和军装是滑稽的，让种族蒙羞。“加维必须走”（Garvey Must Go）运动向执法部门施压，要求他们加倍调查 UNIA。
Garvey was eventually locked up for almost three years for mail fraud. In 1927, he was deported to Jamaica. UNIA shrank severely after that, especially in the United States. In 1940, Marcus Garvey died in London. He was 52 years old. "'Show me the race or the nation without a flag, Marcus Garvey once said in a speech, and I will show you a race of people without any pride." In the same address, Marcus Garvey invoked that minstrel tune from 1900.
加维最终因邮件欺诈被关押了近三年。1927 年，他被驱逐出境到牙买加。此后，UNIA 严重萎缩，特别是在美国。1940 年，马库斯·加维在伦敦去世。他 52 岁。“给我看一个没有旗帜的种族或国家，”马库斯·加维曾在一次演讲中说，“我就会给你看一个没有任何自豪感的种族。”在同一次演讲中，马库斯·加维引用了那首 1900 年的吟游诗人曲调。
In song and mimicry, they have said, every race has a flag but the coon. But as far as Garvey was concerned, he'd silenced any notion of a flagless race, with the red, black and green banner that was flying all over the black world. It's been more than 80 years since Marcus Garvey passed, but the UNIA still exists, and members like Moriamah Kamau still salute its century-old banner. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. They always keep the flag up in the house. Sometimes, you know, when I'm going to meetings, I take the big flag on the train or hanging out in my car when I'm riding down the street just so folks can ask, what's that? What country is this? But the red, black, and green has grown way beyond the UNIA.
“在歌曲和模仿中，他们说，每个种族都有旗帜，除了黑鬼。”但就加维而言，他已经用飘扬在整个黑人世界的红、黑、绿旗帜，平息了任何关于“无旗种族”的说法。马库斯·加维去世已经 80 多年了，但 UNIA 仍然存在，像莫里亚·马卡马奥这样的成员仍然向其百年旗帜致敬。哦，是的，是的，是的。他们总是把旗帜挂在屋子里。有时，你知道，当我要去开会时，我会在火车上带着那面大旗，或者当我开车在街上行驶时，把它挂在车里，只是为了让人们问：“那是什么？这是什么国家？”但红色、黑色和绿色已经远远超出了 UNIA。
In the decades after Garvey's death, several African countries incorporated the Pan-African colors into their own national flags as they gained independence. In the US, the red, black, and green colors were prominent during the Black Power movement and the Black Consciousness Renaissance in the 1960s and 70s. Starting in the late 80s, the tricolors were a big part of hip-hop fashion. In a way, the Pan-African flag has done exactly what Garvey had hoped. He made this enduring symbol that transcends any one organization or country or even hemisphere. He created a single flag that's recognized
在加维去世后的几十年里，几个非洲国家在获得独立时将泛非颜色纳入了他们自己的国旗中。在美国，红、黑、绿色在 20 世纪 60 年代和 70 年代的“黑人权力运动”和“黑人意识复兴”期间非常突出。从 80 年代末开始，这三种颜色成为嘻哈时尚的重要组成部分。在某种程度上，泛非旗帜已经完成了加维所希望的一切。他创造了这个超越任何单一组织、国家甚至半球的持久符号。他创造了一面被认可的单一旗帜，
all over the world as the symbol of blackness. Some of those, like I said, in the community who fly the flag, they know it makes them feel good. They may not understand its history, its full power, but they know it represents them as a people. Okay, so I want to say one last thing about the Pan-African flag. I'm a black man. I was born in the U.S. As far back as I know, my family is from this country. They helped build it. My mom worked for the DC government, my dad is a war vet, and so are a bunch of my uncles. My great-grandfather is buried at Arlington National Cemetery. But even with all this family history,
在世界各地作为黑人身份的象征。正如我所说，社区中一些悬挂这面旗帜的人，他们知道这让他们感觉良好。他们可能不了解它的历史、它的全部力量，但他们知道它代表了他们作为一个种族。好了，我想最后说一件事关于泛非旗帜。我是一个黑人。我出生在美国。据我所知，我的家人来自这个国家。他们帮助建立了它。我妈妈为华盛顿特区政府工作，我爸爸是退伍军人，我的很多叔叔也是。我的曾祖父被安葬在阿灵顿国家公墓。但即使有所有这些家庭历史，
for me, there's also the experience of being black in America, which can make safety and belonging feel tenuous. Standing under the stars and stripes is, at best, an uneasy and insecure thing, because the flag stands for lots of things, including imperialism and white supremacy. So for me, it's not a place where I feel at home. Whenever I find myself in neighborhoods where U.S. flags are displayed, unless it's a super black part of town, I get pretty uncomfortable. I don't feel safe.
对我来说，还有作为美国黑人的经历，这会让安全感和归属感变得脆弱。站在星条旗下，充其量是一件不安和不安全的事情，因为这面旗帜代表了很多东西，包括帝国主义和白人至上主义。所以对我来说，这不是一个让我感到宾至如归的地方。每当我发现自己身处悬挂美国国旗的社区时，除非那是黑人聚居区，否则我会感到非常不舒服。我没有安全感。
It's very different with the red, black, and green. If I see someone flying that flag outside of their home or in their business, I may have no idea what that person believes. We may not even like each other, but that flag, the decision to fly that flag, it feels like someone's telling me you're in a place that's safe for Black people. And you know, I think that was a big part of what
红、黑、绿旗帜的情况则大不相同。如果我看到有人在他们的家外或企业里悬挂那面旗帜，我可能根本不知道那个人相信什么。我们甚至可能不喜欢对方，但那面旗帜，悬挂那面旗帜的决定，感觉就像有人在告诉我，你身处一个对黑人来说安全的地方。你知道，我认为那是很大一部分原因。
Garvey wanted to say with the red, black, and green. Black folks in a world that is constantly threatening you come together under this flag and feel safe. We talk about another interesting flag from our history, the Juneteenth flag. After this. Flag Day may be over, but there's another big day coming up later this week that involves its own flag, Juneteenth, which is a portmanteau of June and 19th. Juneteenth has other names too, including Freedom Day or Liberation Day, but by whatever title, the day is really important. It commemorates the emancipation of slaves in the United States, specifically the date
加维想用红色、黑色和绿色来表达。在这样一个不断威胁你的世界里，黑人聚集在这面旗帜下，感到安全。我们来谈谈历史上另一面有趣的旗帜——六月节旗帜。稍后回来。旗帜日可能已经过去了，但本周晚些时候还有一个重要的日子，它有自己的旗帜，那就是“六月节”（Juneteenth），它是“六月”（June）和“十九日”（19th）的合成词。六月节还有其他名称，包括“自由日”或“解放日”，但无论叫什么，这一天都非常重要。它纪念美国奴隶的解放，具体是指
when the end of slavery was enforced by the Union Army in Galveston, Texas on June 19, 1865. The date has been celebrated in many places for over a century, but it wasn't a federally recognized holiday until June 2021. As part of the push for the holiday to be recognized, the founder of the National Juneteenth Celebration Foundation, Ben Haith, designed a Juneteenth flag in 1997. It was then revised in 2000 by Lisa Jean Graff before it was officially flown. This time of year, people ask me about the Juneteenth flag all the time, more and more every year, because it is a great flag.
1865年6月19日，联邦军队在德克萨斯州加尔维斯顿强制结束奴隶制的日期。这个日期在许多地方已经被庆祝了一个多世纪，但直到2021年6月才成为联邦认可的节日。作为推动该节日获得认可的一部分，国家六月节庆祝基金会创始人本·海斯（Ben Haith）于1997年设计了一面六月节旗帜。随后，丽莎·简·格拉夫（Lisa Jean Graff）在2000年对其进行了修改，之后才正式悬挂。每年的这个时候，人们总是问我关于六月节旗帜的问题，而且一年比一年多，因为它是一面很棒的旗帜。
It's really lovely. Like the American flag, the Juneteenth flag is red, white, and blue, which is a more striking choice to me since all the stuff I learned from Christopher's reporting in this episode about the Pan-African red, black, and green flag. The Juneteenth flag features a central white star referencing the Lone Star State, where the last of the country's enslaved population finally learned of their freedom in 1865. And around that is another 12-pointed white star outline. And together they symbolize a star of Texas bursting with new freedom throughout the land
它真的很可爱。和美国国旗一样，六月节旗帜也是红、白、蓝三色，这对我来说是一个更引人注目的选择，因为我从克里斯托弗在本集节目中关于泛非红、黑、绿旗帜的报道中学到了很多东西。六月节旗帜的中心是一颗白星，象征着“孤星之州”，即1865年该国最后一批被奴役的人口最终获知他们自由的地方。周围还有一个12角白星轮廓。它们共同象征着德克萨斯之星在全国范围内迸发出新的自由
over a new horizon. That horizon consists of a red arch meeting the blue sky above. To quote the creators of the flag, the red, white, and blue colors communicate that American slaves and their descendants were all Americans. Sometimes the flag is shown with the Juneteenth date, June 19, 1865, written across the fly end. Frankly, this is not my favorite edition, but the basic Juneteenth flag, June 19th, 1865, written across the fly end. Frankly, this is not my favorite edition, but the basic Juneteenth flag is top drawer. It is a good flag, as is the red, black, and green.
越过新的地平线。地平线由红色的拱门与上方的蓝天相接而成。引用旗帜设计者的话说，红、白、蓝三种颜色传达了美国奴隶及其后代都是美国人的信息。有时旗帜上会写有六月节的日期“1865年6月19日”。坦率地说，这不是我最喜欢的版本，但基本的六月节旗帜是一流的。它是一面好旗帜，红、黑、绿旗帜也是如此。
So if you fly them together, get ready to talk about all the interesting history that we discussed in the show with the people who pass by. This episode of 99% Invisible originally aired in 2021. It was produced by Christopher Johnson, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, music by Swan Real, mixed by Amita Ganatra. Kathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor.
所以如果你把它们挂在一起，准备好和路过的人谈谈我们在节目中讨论的所有有趣的历史。本集《99%隐形》最初于2021年播出。由克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑，音乐由Swan Real创作，阿米塔·加纳特拉混音。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。
The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Martine Gonzalez, Vivian Ley, Lashma Don, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of Visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. And if you wanna hear another brand new episode of 99% invisible
团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、马丁·冈萨雷斯、薇薇安·雷、拉什玛·唐、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普莱姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区，在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。如果你想收听《99%隐形》的另一集全新节目
One week early and ad free subscribe to Sirius XM podcast plus on Apple podcasts or visit Sirius XM comm slash podcasts plus to listen to Spotify or any other app of your choice You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as her own discord server There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
提前一周且无广告，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Sirius XM Podcast Plus，或访问Sirius XM com slash podcasts plus，以便在Spotify或您选择的任何其他应用程序上收听。您可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。在99PI.org上有一个链接，以及《99PI》过去的所有剧集。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。